endlich verstehe ich den heilig verstehe
ist jetzt ich habe am wochenende
vielleicht einen ganz kleinen kater
gehabt vielleicht habe ich den ganzen
sonntag will kann der chance auf disney
plus geschaut
keine werbung hier an dieser stelle also
keine bezahlt und ich verstehe es jetzt
ich verstehe die faszination um diese
familie ich habe vorher schon keeping up
with the kardashians geschaut aber ich
habe es nie kitschig aber nun gehörig
endlich zum klub auf instagram habe ich
diese neue obsession schon geteilt aber
es ist auch zeit euch meine ein youtube
familie davon zu berichten führer leute
jetzt aber was damit die kardashians mit
gurken zu tun in einer folge schneidet
kendall jenner eine gurke auf so
ungewöhnliche weise das ist ein noch
lange beschäftigt
sich den clip nicht finde oder nicht
benutzen kann ich habe es einmal in
meiner insta story nachgespielt
ungefähr so war es und um diesen vorfall
gemeinsam verarbeiten zu können werde
ich heute in den ganzen tag nur gurken
rezepte kochen und ihr das mir dabei
zuzuschauen
kenne ich bin auf diese video idee
gekommen dachte ich schau mal nach was
es so viel gurken rezepte gibt
wahlaussage gurken scheiben schneiden
und sie mir aufs brot legen habe ich
nicht viel mit dem gemüse zu tun aber es
stellt sich heraus es gibt sehr viele
kuchenrezepte viele davon klinge auf
ersten blick relativ eklig aber wir
werden es herausfinden und die frage
wann es aber warum siehst du denn so aus
als ob du ins fitnessstudio ist weil ich
jetzt ins fitnessstudio gehe und danach
einkaufen werde und dann geht's auch
schon los mit dem ersten rezept
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so jetzt haben wir genug gurten und kann
loslegen das oberteil übertrieben ich
denke nicht mehr und zum frühstück gibt
es ganz klassisch einen gurken apfel
ingwer smoothie damit man auch schön in
seiner modelinie bleibt die zubereitung
war ganz einfach ich habe eine kugel
geschält dann habe ich ein ingwer
geschält ungefähr 1000 groß und ein
apfel geschält und dann habe ich eine
zitrone halbiert und den saft einer
hälfte genommen im anschluss kommt alles
in den mixer rein und wird einmal schon
mal durch gemixt und dann folgen 200
milliliter wasser und der zitronensaft
und dann nochmal schön kurieren abfüllen
und fertig und da ich selber noch nie
ausprobiert habe probleme jetzt erst mal
sauer und zuviel zitronensaft sagte mich
dieses frühstück jetzt nicht machen es
schmeckt aber dafür sehr lecker frisch
und wer zitrone ich nicht glaube so ein
gurken zu sie es wirklich ein toller
start in den tag aber jetzt freue ich
mal was richtiges zu essen und hier
haben wir schon das nächste gericht
gebratene gurke mit spiegeleiern die
zubereitung war relativ simpel zuerst
habe ich die gurgel geschält dann habe
ich die möhren geschält und dann habe
ich die kartoffeln geschält anschließend
habe ich alles mit einer reibe gerieben
dass geriebene gemüse kommt nun in ein
sieb damit es noch abtropfen kann denn
die gurke ist ziemlich nass ich weiß
auch nicht warum in dem rezept nicht
drin stand dass man das innere der gurke
auskratzen soll denn das ist ja wirklich
ziemlich nass danach habe ich eine
zwiebel geschält und geschnitten und das
gleiche mit dem knoblauch gemacht dann
ein bisschen öl in die pfanne zwiebel
und knoblauch rein und erstmal ein
bisschen an beraten lassen darauf folgte
das gerasterte gemüse und das erst mal
für zehn minuten anbraten in der zeit
habe ich noch mein frischen dünn
geschnitten und natürlich nicht
vergessen zu würzen mit salz pfeffer und
muskatnuss und dann wurde alles wieder
miteinander verrührt und als dann alles
zehn minuten anbraten durfte kam frische
kräuter dazu also der dill und gefrorene
petersilie ich habe gefrorene petersilie
war ist einfach praktischer finde aber
man kann natürlich auch frische nehmen
und dann kommt noch ein schöner dafür
butter dazu und frischkäse und haben
aber es miteinander verrührt und für
weitere fünf minuten gebraten fertig und
als beilage empfiehlt das rezept sich
ein spiegelei zu machen also habe ich
mit zwei gemacht denn ich liebe spieler
so einfach war das dass es fast keine
jobs schaffen würde und ich finde dieses
rezept so skurril weil ich noch nie
gurke gebraten habe also ich hab ich
noch nie in meinem leben war mit gurken
gegessen wurde ob das schmeckt finden
wir jetzt heraus
das ist so
sie ist gemüse so frisch gerieben habe
dachte ich so berichtet aber ganz schön
nach gurk ich verlinke euch alle rezepte
und gebiert das mal aus das ist wirklich
sehr sehr lecker das ist eine richtig
leckere beilage
warum habe ich in meinem leben noch wie
warme google gegessen 10 von 10 ich
finde das so lecker also bestimmt ist
also auch geschmackssache aber
guckt euch das an toll toll toll ist das
jetzt erst mal auf und dann spannen mich
ein bisschen und wir sehen uns aber
jetzt zum nächsten snack und zum
abendessen gibt es überbackene gurke und
koreanischen gurkensalat willkommen das
sieht schon ganz schön gut aus ist der
kartoffel habe ich heute nicht wirklich
krebs gehabt wenn auf einer guten diät
das ist ein koreanischer gurken salat
und der war wirklich einfach zu machen
zuerst nimmt jährlich eine gurke und wie
schneidet ihr dann in der hälfte durch
dann kratzt man mal wieder das innere
von der burg raus weil es nass ist und
man schneidet die gurke halten so schöne
mundgerechte stücke so wie man es halt
am liebsten markt kleiner möglichkeit
dieses kleiner wenn die größe mögt dann
halt größer die gruppen packte dann in
eine schale und da fügt ihr dann alle
restlichen zutaten zu zucker
chiliflocken
sojasauce rise fx und geröstete sesamöl
und das wird dann alles miteinander
vermengt und einfach im kühlschrank
gepackt für so 20 minuten dann sollte es
gut durchgezogen sagt und bevor ihr den
gurkensalat senden er hat muss da noch
ein kleines i tüpfelchen drauf sein und
ich nehme jetzt schwarzen ihr könnt
natürlich auch weiß nehmen gerösteten so
wie es mit staat so cool aus hübsch
merke einfach obwohl ich so gerne
koreanisch esse dass ich das nie
versuche selber zu kochen und ich glaube
viele gerichte sind gar nicht so schwer
wie man denkt wie zum beispiel
eingelegte gurken
sehr scharf fresh weil es wirke ist
sesamöl klick gut rein sie sagen
obendrauf gut rein ich glaube es könnte
aber sogar noch länger eingelegt weil
ich habe es mir ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen aufregender vorgestellt
vielleicht gibt es auch rezepte die
müssen mehr beinhalten reicht es ist
dann auch mit reis besser aber es kann
auch sein dass meine gucke noch ein bis
hin zu nass war man sie so ricky
abtrocknet ist vielleicht der geschmack
ein bisschen intensiver weil es dann
nicht von dem wasser so abgetropft wird
aber so als kleine beilage kann man das
auf jeden fall machen kommen wir hier zu
unserem hauptabend gericht sieht doch
aus wie so ein komisches diät low carb
pizza gericht jeder ist lasagne oder
nudelteig bisschen wie so ditz wo man
halt nudeln aus zucchini essen können
und dann spart man sich die
kohlenhydrate weil wir wollen alle
einfach nur schlank sein spaß stimmt
mich für die überbackene gurke steht
immer wieder eine gurke dann schneidet
man die gurken der hälfte durch und
kratzt mal wieder das innere aus die
gurken hälften legt man dann in eine
auflaufform beträufelt sie noch ein
bisschen mit sojasoße dann schneidet ihr
euch eine zwiebel
berät sie anpackt hackfleisch dazu in
meinem fall vegetarisches hackfleisch
und schneidet noch ein paar champignons
und die kommen auch noch in die pfanne
dann lass dir das alles schön durch
beraten und füllt die gurken mit der akv
live masse dann kommt noch
selbstgemachter tomatensoße obendrauf
oder wie in meinem fall aus der dose und
das ganze wird garniert mit streut käse
und das hat jetzt kommt dann in den
backofen bei 180 grad für eine halbe
stunde also so lange bis der käse halt
super dunkelbraun wird
und dann holt jetzt raus und fertig also
meine go kart auf jeden fall noch
nie zeigen ich will ein schönes stück
für die kamera
des looks amazing heute habe ich so
verrückte sachen gegessen
moment ich muss weiter probieren
ich bin überrascht das ist nicht so
dass fribourg man hat schon so einen
richtigen gurken tat aber es schmeckt
nicht wie zum beispiels der vorspeisen
salate frische gurke sondern eher so
eine schmucke gurken würde jetzt mögen
das ist zum beispiel eine kartoffel
ersetzt oder nudelteig oder so also
etwas was dann wirklich so dieses
kohlenhydrate nochmal eine in die fresse
rein es schmeckt schon nach einer diät
gericht es ist wirklich genießbar s-bahn
nicht dass jetzt zum abendessen würde
ich mich danach wohl fühlen und gutes
gefühl haben nicht so ich muss mir jetzt
ihr liebling fremd also außer dass er
gurkhas wo sie heute morgen nicht so
wirklich aufregend war und ihr denn alle
wahrscheinlich schon kennt waren heute
echt coole gerichte dabei ich bin
wirklich erstaunt vor allem über warme
brücke warmen gockel lasst euch das mal
auf der zunge zergehen soli warme gurke
natürlich
es ist schon spät leute es spielt ich
habe gerade so schön ein weg moderiert
und habe dann gesehen dass die kamera
nicht läuft also wir machen jetzt einen
zitronenkuchen granite das ist das
dessert für heute dafür habe ich schon
gut vorbereitet und zwar habe ich sie
geschält in scheiben geschnitten dieser
stelle gibt es gleich ein kleines
tutorial und kendall jenner so schneidet
man eine gurke also nicht aber so
jetzt weiß es ja und jetzt habe ich noch
eine zitrone ausgepresst und ein
bisschen honig in den mixer eingepackt
und jetzt wollte ich noch ein bisschen
wasser rein machen ich habe wirklich so
schön ich habe tolle stimmung aber die
uhrzeit das ist schon ein bisschen
später dann wird hier ein abguss musik
ja jetzt sollen dann noch also für ein
liegt natürlich wieder ganz toll nach
kurz das war heute ein wilder gurken
ritt hier ist unser nachtisch auf dieses
video
[Musik]
das ist nicht schlecht aber es schmeckt
wirklich noch gefroren hanke main
weniger favorit heute ihr euch das video
gefallen ich auf die findelkinder weiß
jetzt wie man gucken zubereitet wir
sehen uns das nächste mal wieder zu
einem neuen video macht das nach alle
rezepte in der von box abonnieren ich
war jetzt daumen nach oben wir auch
nicht